la parole est maintenant monsieur Loïc
Hervé pour le groupe Union centriste
pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues avant toute chose et
comme tous les collègues qui se
succèdent à cette tribune cet après-midi
je tiens à saluer le travail
exceptionnel qui a été effectué par
notre délégation droit des femmes en
particulier par nos collègues la
présidente Billon et nos collègues
Alexandra borchio Fontain Laurence Cohen
et Laurence Rossignol auteur du rapport
d'information porno l'enfer du décor not
émane la présente proposition de
résolution il s'agit d'un travail
véritablement pionnier aussi incroyable
que cela soit alors que la pornographie
est à l'évidence devenue un problème
social majeur le Parlement ne l'avait
jamais véritablement investi
avec ce rapport de formation et cette
proposition de résolution la
représentation nationale ouvre enfin les
yeux il était temps contre les préjugés
les plus communément répandus c'est
évidemment tout à l'honneur de notre
haute assemblée d'avoir porté cette
prise de conscience je tiens donc à
affirmer sans ambiguïté que je soutiens
sans réserve chacun des considérants de
cette proposition de résolution dont je
suis moi-même consignateur
la question qui est devant nous est
importante madame la ministre après la
publication du rapport l'adoption je
l'imagine tout à l'heure de cette
résolution
tout cela nous entraînera madame la
ministre sans doute vers un texte de loi
et posera nécessairement la question
d'adoption de mesure pragmatiques pour
être efficace
l'interdiction pure et simple de la
pornographie est un chemin que certains
de nos collègues nous proposeront
peut-être d'emprunter sans préempter sur
ce débat je crois pouvoir affirmer que
la prohibition pourrait générer
immédiatement la bascule de la
pornographie dans la contrebande et la
mafia qu'ils ont des mots encore pire
que ceux que nous connaissons déjà
aujourd'hui et qui ont été longuement
évoqués existe-t-il une pornographie
éthique existe-t-il une pornographie
morale est-ce notre rôle d'y répondre
dans les débats à venir je serai de ceux
qui défendront un encadrement strict
c'est un chemin de crête qui demande de
la conviction mais qui a mes yeux et le
seul qui soit en mesure de produire de
réels effets sur la réalité vécue dans
notre pays alors pour encadrer la
pornographie nous avons tout à fait et
c'est bien ce travail que nous invite à
mes yeux encore une fois
cette présente résolution
la seule pornographie qui puisse exister
se doit de respecter la loi mais avant
tout la personne humaine et bien
évidemment les femmes
c'est une pornographie d'alcool de
d'adulte consentants et qui ne s'adresse
qu'à eux aucune tolérance pour les viols
ce sont des crimes aucune tolérance pour
les abus de faiblesse ni la prostitution
et encore moins le proxénétisme c'est
d'ailleurs ce que considère la Cour de
cassation qui dans sa décision du 18 mai
à
refuser d'étendre la définition
jurisprudentielle de la notion de
prostitution à l'activité dite de kaming
constituant à proposer moyennant
rémunération une diffusion d'image ou de
vidéos à contenu sexuel pour séparer le
bon grain de livret un cadre transversal
doit être créé de toute pièce car
schématiquement on peut classer les
problèmes causés par la pornographie en
deux grandes familles
ce lié aux personnes qui la font et se
lier aux personnes qui ont accès la
protection des premières c'est à dire
principalement des actrices
posent la question des conditions de
travail ça a été évoqué par plusieurs
collègues et des conditions de tournage
dans la production de tout ces contenus
pornographiques c'est la seule solution
pour prévenir les crimes telles que ceux
qui ont récemment défrayé la chronique
et qui sont d'ailleurs devant des
juridictions de notre pays c'est sont
même ces crimes qui sont à l'origine de
notre prise de conscience collective
quant à l'énorme problème de l'accès de
nos enfants et de nos adolescents il
soulève l'impérieuse nécessité des
plates que les plateformes soient
contraintes à vérifier l'âge la CNIL a
fait des propositions et il y a un
monsieur le Président je suis un peu
long mais il y a eu un élément qui est
très important et j'en terminerai par là
et qui a un autre dieu doit être un
élément de réflexion c'est la régulation
également des messageries instantanées
qui sont un champ extrêmement important
vous l'aurez compris dans mes propos le
groupe de l'Union centriste votera cette
proposition de résolution sans aucune
réserve
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant